okay welcome
I'd like to warmly welcome everybody to
today's exciting and stimulating line of
speakers we're delighted to have such a
gathering of esteemed historians and
social scientists with us at Yale and
are grateful that they have made time
out of their busy schedules to share
with us some of their scholarship and
insights into possible intersections
between religion and conflict the
Macmillan Center initiative on religion
politics and society is in its first
year of operation it's designed to be an
interdisciplinary home for scholars and
students from around the University in
an examination of problems relating to
religion and politics understood in its
broadest sense through a range of forums
the initiative is seeking to promote an
open-minded and fresh look at if how and
why religion impacts politics and
society to this end the initiative is
organizing or co-sponsoring two
subsequent conferences this semester the
first is on Islam and politics of
political reform coming up on March 1st
followed by a two-day extravaganza event
organized in honor of the distinguished
historian Charles Taylor on April 4th
and 5th I hope that many of you here
today will be able to attend those
events as well it will come as no
surprise to anyone that among the
primary concerns of the religion and
politics initiative is the intersection
of religion and conflict today's event
is the first of several conferences that
we will be organizing in order to
examine questions relating to it what we
hope to achieve today is to begin a
sustained conversation among social
scientists and historians but whether
there is such a thing as religious
conflict that can be analytically
distinguished from other forms of
conflict
alternatively is religious conflict
simply epiphenomenon
that is derivative of other more deeper
material forces if there is indeed such
a thing as religious conflict then in
one specific ways does it differ from
other forms of conflict and violence are
there specific and unique mechanisms
that at work and religious conflict and
violence that make its manifestations
more intense and less tractable to
instruments of conflict resolution are
there recurring patterns and if so what
explains variations and patterns of
conflict the religious conflict across
time and space while I have no illusions
that we will have resolved any of these
questions by dinnertime I fully expect
the today's event will launch us on a
stimulating and fascinating day of
discussion and reflection on this most
important of topics to launch us on that
path I am honored and privileged to be
able to introduce to you our
distinguished keynote speaker professor
Robert I've more whose work on this
topic of on this topic in the context of
medieval Europe over several decades has
been elegant and provocative professor
Moore was a professor of medieval
history at the University of Newcastle
upon Tyne until his recent retirement he
previously taught at Sheffield
University and was a visiting professor
at the University of Chicago his
previous books include the birth of
popular heresy the origins of European
descent the formation of a persecuting
Society and the first European
revolution he's also the general editor
of the Blackwell history of the world
series professor Moore will be
delivering a talk entitled religion
violence in the historian please join me
in extending a warm
but thank you very much professor Sharma
for those kind words and even much more
much more for inviting me here to this
splendid splendid occasion just before
the third year after the Millennium
throughout the whole world but most
especially in Italy and Gaul men began
to reconstruct churches although for the
most part the existing ones were
properly built and not in the least
unworthy but it seemed as though each
Christian community was aiming to
surpass all the others in the splendor
of construction It was as if the whole
world was shaking itself free struggling
shrugging off the past and padding
itself everywhere in a white mantle of
churches those words of the chronicler
Rallo bear of the board writing around
10:40 may be familiar to a good many of
you for their regularly quoted in
textbooks of medieval history as
emblematic of a transformation of
Europe's fortunes that began at the
beginning of the second millennium CE II
the past which was shrugged off
according to the firmly established
orthodoxy was characterized above all by
violence Europe had been devastated by
the invasions of mock Vikings Magyars
and Saracens from without and the
ceaseless and bloody warring of its
feudal aristocracy within in the
eleventh and twelfth centuries
Western Europe emerged from violence in
many forms especially barbarian invasion
and private warfare or feudal Anarchy a
form of lawlessness so called because it
pursued the family interests of the
protagonists rather than a perceived
public interest perceived that is to say
by historians such as state or nation
building for the expansion of Europe or
more grandly of civilization that is
invading and conquer
the barbarians instead of being invaded
by them as that last point reminds us
there's violence and violence the 12th
and 13th centuries are still regarded
and in my view rightly as one of the
great creative ages of order and advance
in European history when the National
monarchies which became the states of
modern Europe with portentous exceptions
of Germany and Italy established a sway
of their unruly subjects promulgating
law codes to proclaim it and building
institutions to realize it under a
dynamic and innovative papacy I'm sorry
I lost my pleasure in the promulgating
laughers to proclaim it and building
institutions to realize it in the
secular sphere as the church reorganized
and reinvigorated under dynamic and
innovative papacy did in spiritual it
was no coincidence that these
developments took place simultaneously
with one of the great cultural
flowerings of European history
Raoul may have been a monk but his
vision of lavish patronage of the church
and by extension the arts and learning
as the preeminent indicator of peace and
order was universal assessment of the
level of violence is not a simple matter
for any Society at any period and has
recently been the subject of a good deal
of controversy one way and another for
this one but it's not evident generate
not self-evident that violence
diminished in the 11th century or even
in the 12th if only because most of the
achievements which have commanded the
admiration of posterity depended on it
those same textbooks that quote Raoul a
bear follow him up as likely as not with
abbot Suja is equally famous portrait of
the incessant expeditions skirmishes and
sieges by which King Louie the 6th of
France
reduced to submission the turbulent
baron
of the ile-de-france Lewis contemporary
Henry the first the English Lion of
Justice was faith famed and feared for
the cruelty with which he punished his
enemies
Henry's grandson Henry the second the
father of English common law exercised
his rulership through the agencies of
Biss at voluntas era at malevolent air
power and arbitrary will anger and
malice ruthlessly deployed to keep his
enemies in terror and his friends in
perpetual uncertainty if the 13th
century was the great age of European
law codes it was also that of the
classification and persecution of all
manner of minorities of the
proliferation of cruel and unusual
punishments of the institutionalization
of torture it's unnecessary to labor
further at the point that chroniclers
and hence historians were a lot more
likely to approve of violence that they
didn't do sit on critically when it was
carried out by acknowledged office
holders in the name of public objectives
the establishment of authority the
maintenance of order the expansion of
kingdoms and so on in this respect the
vocabulary and judgments of the great
19th century historians who established
disbanded account of the progress of
European civilization reflected have on
Lillet Faber's classic definition of the
state as the monopoly of legitimate
violence the writers of throath century
naturally enough preferred recourse to
the sacred the peace of all things
Augustine had said may in the
tranquility of the divinely ordained
order it was their position within it
which legitimated and indeed required
the violence of legitimate authorities
they and their successors also greatly
extended the circumstances in which the
church was prepared to give its blessing
to violence most obviously when it was
directed against non-christians
those developments will not be pursued
further here my concern this morning is
with violence carried on under the
banner of religion within Latin or
Catholic or Western society by
Christians against other Christians
it may be roughly classified under four
headings in descending order of former
public sanction as warlike repressive
inter-communal and insurrection in the
first category in the Alba Jensen
crusade from twelve eight to twelve
twenty nine was one of the bitterest and
most momentous wars in European history
it was not the first to have been
justified by the heterodoxy of the
victim religious difference real or
alleged was not the only issue that
fuelled it or even the most important it
is at least arguable that the redrawing
of the emerging European national state
system which it precipitated was of much
more lasting significance than any
religious outcome but this was the first
time that religion was invoked as
justification for an attack by Catholic
Christians on a Christian and devoured
by catholic principality the spirit in
which it was conducted or at least that
in which it was remembered is famously
epitomized in the legend will reply of
legendary possibly in both senses of the
papal Leggett when he was asked after
the fall of Asia in 12:9 how the
victorious Crusaders were to distinguish
among the defeated citizenry between
heretics and Catholics kill them all the
Lord will know his own for
contemporaries and in memory this was a
religious war like none before it and
very few after in European history
perhaps the hussite was in the 15th
century the German peasants Wars and
French Wars of Religion the 16th the 30
Years War in the 17th religious rhetoric
and musical demonization
polarised the protagonists intensified
the brutality of the conflict and
prolonged it by blocking possible
resolutions it also became self
fulfilling the categories on the one
hand Catholic on the other hand the many
labels bestowed on various groups of
dissenters both real and imaginary were
hardened and entrenched conceptually and
to an increasing extent in reality it's
easy with hindsight to note how the
defense of the faith had over the
centuries become increasingly permissive
in respect of those against whom the use
of violence might be condoned or gustan
against his own earlier convictions and
those of many of his Christian
contemporaries had devised a
justification for the coercion of
heretics that the church long remained
firmly opposed to killing and war even
against pagans in the 12th century the
alleged propensity of Celtic
Christianity to generate heresy had been
called in aid of military and political
expansion over Catholics they're not
necessarily obedient monarchy into Wales
and Ireland increasingly violent polemic
against the Greeks including the chance
that they were heretics and fermenters
of heresy formed part of the background
to the conquest and sack of
Constantinople by the army of the Fourth
Crusade in 1204 whether that atrocity
was planned and if so by whom remains
uncertain but if there was a design it
was for greed not religion and was
immediately denounced in the strongest
terms by the same curve innocent the
third who launched the emergency and who
said four years later nobody tried then
or later to justify or excuse it and the
common anxiety of the narrative sources
is to minimize the roads of their heroes
and patrons in the events that led up to
it the case of the Alba Jensen crusade
correctly so called the
the Pope had since 12:4 been offering
the spiritual incentives and immunities
associated with more in the holy land to
those that would take up arms against
the country to lose is very different
the contemporary narrative sources with
one exception are coarsely and brutally
celebratory and their substance and
until quite recently their tone has
shaped a historiography ever since the
harmony of Catholic piety and French
nationalism on that point until very
recently it is expressed in the title of
a standard text book Lacroix said
console is Debbie's wife a new yoga
Languedoc ala France Paris 1942 and the
date is not a material almost all modern
narratives repeat the story that
Catholicism was on the verge of
extinction in the Languedoc a land long
riven by the monarchy and heresy of the
Cathars against which its nobles led by
its principal Lord and Raymond the sixth
of 2news declined to act leaving the
Pope with no choice but to do so
especially after the murder of his [ __ ]
who had excommunicated the country by
one of Raymond's officials in January
twelve hundred and eight well that's a
very long way from the whole truth what
matters from our present point of view
is that while the average ensign wars
were undoubtedly religious by any
possible test their origins were not
they lay in long-standing and
complicated competing political claims
which were rooted in the last resort not
in the culture but in the geography of
the region the counts of Toulouse were
historically among the most honored
vessels of the French crown one of them
a leader of the first was safe their
remoteness from the northern centres of
royal power had given them the next a
degree of independence and prestige they
were uniquely permitted for example not
to attend the
coronation or solemn courts for others
an indispensable test of loyalty but
they had also since the middle of cross
central a trait the geographical
position had all says since the middle
of the 12th century exposed him
increasingly to the ambitions of others
including the papacy itself as well as
the kings of Aragon and of England it
was the propaganda of the last that
generated the image of heresy spreading
like a cancer from Toulouse through
Gastonia neighboring regions which
remorselessly repeated through the last
decades of that century provided the
rationale for the assault that innocent
the third released in 1208
the accusation was first promulgated by
a Council of the church which are just
quoted in 1163 less remarkable to the
faculties was presided over by Pope
Alexander the third at that moment
heavily dependent on the support of
Henry the second then that it was held
in Henry's favorite City earth tour and
on his instructions
packed by his bishops four years after
the greatest military expedition of his
reign against Toulouse had been
frustrated by the intervention of the
French King Louis the 7th such an
intervention could not be easily
repeated if the count of Toulouse were
branded a protector of heresy the
courtiers of henry ii were probably not
the first european statesmen to
understand that if you repeat something
often enough and loudly enough people
begin to think there must be something
in it but they exploited it with rare
skill and over the following decades
many with varying degrees of credulity
and vested interests took up the message
as historians have done ever since there
was a sliver of truth to lend initial
plausibility to this caricature of the
religious temper temper of the long dark
or occitania
the ecclesiastical reform which since
the ten sixties had been vigorously
their petroleum force
in the more advanced parts of Europe
made little headway here when Bernard of
Clairvaux
visited the region in 1145 he was
scandalized by the absence of the key
measures associated with this reform
including more centralized control of a
clerical preferment more uniform
practices in relation to baptism penance
and burial and especially the payment of
tithes by that time however attempts to
introduce them with Bernhard's efforts
doubtless encouraged were arousing local
resentment and resistance especially in
the castellated villages of the
countryside over the following decades
the resentment increased and with it the
influence of the local champions and
spokesmen of the traditional ways of
doing things often referred to by a
conventional courtesy as good men by now
broadly the same forces in varying
contexts and combinations were bringing
about increasing social distance and
deteriorating relations between the
clergy especially the higher clergy and
the laity in other parts of Europe
disputes over the control of
ecclesiastical appointments and
resentment of growing financial demands
generated increasingly acrimonious
accusations of avarice and corruption on
the one side and a Pharisee on the other
in Italy Flanders and the Rhineland in
the eleven fifties sixties and seventies
when the leaders of the church as a
whole had the opportunity to compare
notes at the third natural Council of
1179 after almost 20 years of schism
they concluded that they were confronted
everywhere by a body of heretics
and I quote whom some call Kothari some
patter Eenie and some publicani
but which into news and its
neighbourhood had assumed such
proportions that they practice their
wickedness
in secret but preach their error
publicly on that basis another 20 years
of strident publicity prepared the wave
the Argentine crusade and for the
establishment and empowerment of the
papal Inquisition most actively in the
Languedoc northern Italy and the
Rhineland in inverting the violence
associated with that institution
incidentally we should bear in mind that
it was in a sense reciprocal they're
certainly not symmetrical in choosing
the stake rather than the recantation
which they were invariably and usually
genuinely offered the victims in effect
accepted the inquisitors understanding
of the nature of the conflict in which
they were joined all asceticism is
neatly remarked and martyrdom especially
is a form of aggression that's putting
it briefly is how those who attacked and
eventually conquered and colonized the
long-ago
became persuaded or persuaded themselves
that they did so in defense of their
Catholic faith it's not how its pitted
their victims to whom the aggressors
were the French or the Crusaders from
the beginning nor did the war have the
effect as of course the invaders hoped
it would of exacerbating the division
between Catholics and heretics in the
native population on the contrary
statements and the effect that heretics
could not be denounced or ostracized
because they were friends and relations
are quite common in this respect the
account of the low-doc constructed by
pre crusade propaganda was true
Catholics and heretics lived side by
side without obvious signs of animosity
or mutual hostility as late as the
twelve 20s in the memory of those
questioned in the gradient positions of
twelve forty five to forty six open
debate between Catholics and heretics
was quite normal in the village
Laura's a and seldom attended by
violence or the threat of it that's not
to say that there were never any
disagreements between them about other
things Paul that when there were the
religious difference may not have been
cited as or in fact of being an element
of it but it wasn't a general or
profound source of social division
within operatin society either before or
after the wars the role of religion in
the abbot Jensen crusade was to assure
the attackers of the righteousness of
their cause and by dehumanizing their
opponents to dissolve whatever
inhibitions might have restrained the
ferocity of their conduct on the
battlefield and towards the Concord and
their lands though it should be added
that the extent of certain emissions was
not great in any theatre of 13th century
warfare an obvious implication of these
facts is that the division between
Catholics and heretics did not
correspond to any profound or general
fissure in oxygen society appoint a more
noteworthy because by all accepted
accounts the region was politically
extremely fragmented
and socially highly diverse experts on
it which I am not offer differing
accounts of the social basis of heresy
and in particular of the relationship
between its currency and the villagers
at the courts of the greatest of the
nobles and among the citizens of the
largest times what pretty obvious is
that no simple class-based analysis is
likely to be right and that if heresy
arrived in the Languedoc before or more
than a few years before the Crusaders a
view which as I've said I don't share it
did not have success to its appeal to
any single sector of the population well
if the conclusion that heresy per se was
not socially divisive in the Modoc seems
at first
prising it's in part because the
category heresy is itself unhelpful
there's no necessary or my observational
simple correlation between the doctrines
of religious groups and their social
role and dynamics we make terrify the
issue by returning two hundred years or
so to the period at which popular
religious movements appear as a major
force in European social history the
classic case and the best-documented is
that as the Patroons who from the ten
50s until the ten seventies kept the
city of milan in turmoil with their
attacks including physical attacks on
the archbishop and clergy of the city
the campaign was directed at the clergy
who were married or who paid for their
benefits because the elimination of
simony and clerical marriage was at the
heart of the program of the Gregorian
reform which reset the church over the
next two centuries of which the patterns
provided an advance guard they have
never been classified as heretics there
it's at least probable that their
leaders subscribed to the very serious
doughnut list heresy the one that had
caused August them to embrace coercion
that sacraments conferred by unworthy
priests were invalid conversely the
practices that were attacked were
neither new nor peculiar to Milan
although the Milanese clergy claimed
that marriage was permitted to them by a
special tradition sanctioned by their
patron saint ambrose and traffic in
performance had been routinely organized
since the archbishop distributed the
lands of his diocese as feats among its
leading families known as the capital a
in 983 and had been particularly blatant
as the rapid growth of a money economy
made payment in cash increasingly common
but marriage especially the lower clergy
was general everywhere in Europe
time and clerical positions and the
revenues they carried had been a major
instrument of patronage and the
lucrative ingredient of Senor real
estates at least since the ninth century
this did not prevent the patrons and
their allies in Rome from characterizing
those who them from characterizing them
as respectively their racist Nikolai
Etana
and the Horatius simony opera the
patterning movement was both violent
than socially divisive if you had seen
the city with its deserted palazzi and
now fallen towers one chronicler
complained you would have concluded that
you were amidst the ruins of Babylon not
Milan once the Nergal seat of the
kingdom the word pot area from which the
movement takes its name is thought to
have referred to the ragpickers who were
the lowliest casual workers of the cloth
trade but its leaders were from Knightly
families and its patrons included
merchants and bankers priests were
attacked in their houses and forced to
give up their wives at least one church
was seized and taken over by the rebels
on the other side
riots and popular protests against the
clergy were brutally suppressed by the
armed henchmen of the capital a families
who roamed the streets butchering and
torturing at will the divisions created
or reflected in those events however
were not only of class no that and this
is a point to which I'll return at least
partly because it was a religious
movement inspired by eloquent preaching
and united by shared worship and common
ritual practices as well as by religious
rhetoric it also divided families
one household was entirely faithless
faithful that is for the chronicler Pro
Katerina and the next entirely faithless
in the third the mother believes with
one son while the father disbelieved
with another son in this the patrons
with characteristics of the evangelical
movement which from the early 11th
century gave rise to a large number of
monastic foundations all over Europe and
which equated the adoption of the
religious life with the disavowal of
family ties and privileges a hundred
years later bernard of clairvaux
main spokesman and propagator of the
Cistercian order was still quite
interest in his insistence that family
ties between parents and children
between husband and wife must always be
sacrificed to the call of the religious
life the patterning is also foreshadowed
not only the program of the Gregorian
reform movement in the church as we've
seen but its tenor and temples the Pope
from whom that reform takes its name
Gregory the 7th through 10th 72 83
flooded Europe with letters that urged
the faithful and note the word not only
to boycott the services of married
priests but to withdraw their obedience
from bishops who failed to obey his
precepts or to carry out his programs
that was a direct incentive to rebellion
and was frequently accepted as such in
Gregory's time and for almost a century
after it the progress of reform in
Europe was regularly accompanied by
civil disobedience boycotts and riots by
the threat and the reality of violence
it must be very doubtful whether the
reform could have prevailed as
eventually it did without it the reasons
for the violence which accomplished both
the monastic movement and the wider
movement of ecclesiastical reform and
not far to seek
those who inspired and conducted it had
been among the losers in a widespread
and ruthless revision of family
structures and succession customs to
secure family pack nominees by
restricting inheritance to a single son
usually the elders this meant excluding
from their customary share and their
livelihood not only daughters but
younger sons and sons of concubines all
of course categories that were in
consequence greatly elevated in
importance and in rigor of definition
the conflicts to which this process gave
rise from late in the 10th century were
often peculiarly savage stories abound
of landings restorations and other
mutilations inflicted by blood relations
including brothers on each other and
obviously designed to exclude the
victims from succession from the point
of view of the family entry to the
religious life either as a month or as a
secular clock was a form of castration
and by no means always voluntary the
anger directed back at the family that
of course is one reason why the
insistence on a celibacy of the clergy
became so important in the middle
decades of the 11th century the anger
directed back at the family by the
religious is well-known in the creation
of a religious culture founded on the
content of the world and its impurities
but two other expressions of that anger
shaped the future of Europe first an
elegant resolution of the property
question was worked out painfully and
piecemeal through the eleventh and
twelfth centuries the elimination of
clerical marriage and the traffic and
clerical office amounted to removing the
church and its property and prerogatives
from family control on the other hand
legitimation and consolidation of the
dynastic principle required the
cooperation
the church that is of the dispossessed
in defining and enforcing the new
understandings of marriage and incest
upon which the dynastic principle was
founded accommodation was secured by
dividing the land and its fruits into
two categories secular and
ecclesiastical access to the one was
controlled by blood and the sword to the
other by Basel ordination and by office
and qualification under either heading
constituted a disqualification under the
other secondly and less overtly the
younger sons with determination and
sophistication increasing through the
period and a considerable measure of
long term success were instrumental in
subordinating the interests and power of
the family to the institutions of church
and monarchy of which the new order of
social castrati
clark's and knights provided both the
theoretical and the executive arms all
of this which I've argued elsewhere
amounted to nothing less than a social
revolution that formed European
civilization with its distinguishing
culture and institutions required as its
first condition the shattering of one
structure of family and kinship among
the warrior class and its replacement by
another based on directly opposing
principles on monogamy in principle
rather than Paula Dean II in practice on
strictly defined hierarchy among
siblings
according to maternity birth order and
gender rather than genuine equality of
opportunity and expectation within the
kindred and in consequence of their
hierarchy on the lifelong and usually
involuntary commitment of in the
two specific roles and functions with
their accompanying privileges and
privations this was achieved without the
aid of any central authority capable of
imposing it either by deference or by
coercion and indeed without conscious
design against all traditional values
and radically against the interests of
arguably the most elementary source of
power in this society young men of
fighting AIDS
two things made the achievement possible
one as I've said was extreme violence
the other was religion in the conditions
of the 11th century perhaps in any
conditions such a transformation of
values as I just described could not be
imposed except in particular local
circumstances and in the very short term
it must be embraced and it could be
embraced only if accepted and
internalized and by the losers as well
as by the winners that is why it was not
only expressed as but needed religious
faith with its power to override
traditional family ties and obligations
and to unite its devotees in
dishonourably to one another and to
their cause in the face of every threat
and every temptation in various terms to
replace the community of blood by a
community of faith and it is the
construction of that community of faith
which provides the link between the two
parts of my argument for it was
precisely in its name and by its most
brilliant architects that the emergency
enforce aid was conceived and carried
out as a crucible and consummation of
the two great constructs which
proclaimed its triumph the Church
Universal and the European nation state
so I might offer you some kind of
conclusion we've seen in the eleventh
and twelfth century in northern Italy
and northern France what we did not see
in the 13th century long dough religion
providing the driving force which
shattered from within old solidarity's
and communities and constituting new
ones as according to the social
theorists it is supposed to do processes
accompanied by a great deal of violence
at all levels it ought to be noted that
this was a far more Universal process
manifested in far more various ways than
I've indicated in this talk the
competitive construction and elaboration
of sacred places as the loci of dynastic
and of neighborhood communities was
hailed by Raghava globba in the
quotation with which I began but I've
said nothing of the multitude of ways in
which people rallied around the bones of
their sinks or acclaim the miracles of
their prophets to resist rapacious Lords
to give identity to new settlements to
proclaim urban communes all of which
activities might easily be and routinely
were accompanied by considerable
violence I've said nothing about the
ways in which both Christians and Jews
became more assertively conscious of
their religious identities and so on
it's not too much to say that the whole
history of Europe in this period could
be written in terms of the formation and
reformation of communities and the
religious expressions and manifestations
of those processes but then of what
region at what period could that not be
said the fundamental question we hope to
begin exploring the organizers of this
offensive to us and I know that my
fellow speakers will join me in thanking
them as warm as warmly as I know how for
asking the question and for the
generosity and hospitality with which
they've invited us to join them in
pursuing it the fundamental question we
hope to begin exploring is if there is
something unique or different about
religion that leads to particular
patterns of conflict across time and
space the formulation implies some kind
of comparison between religion and other
kinds of social or cultural phenomenon
and therefore calls for a definition of
religion itself neither of which I
propose to attempt the best I think my
material can offer at least for the
moment as a possible partial response is
a suggestion as to why the violence
associated with religion is often so
extreme and after the circumstances in
which the combination is likely to arise
I hate enough say however that my
conclusions are so little original that
they're readily accommodated within some
of the most familiar generalities of
social theory some of you indeed may
think that I've said nothing that wasn't
said or at least implied by Weber and by
Durkheim and I plead guilty to that more
directly
max look mom's classic account of peace
in the feud suggests that violence
within communities is self-limiting
because it reaches a point at which the
overlapping cross-cutting
interests of the protagonists make it
counterproductive the currently
prominent notion of multiple identities
as elaborated for instance by sin
similarly points to the multiplicity of
interests and identities possessed by
every individual in varying combinations
as the key source of tolerance and
restraint these are in effect different
expressions at the same point
multiple identities create cross-cutting
ties which among other things imply
recognition of the humanity of opponents
because they share some identities with
oneself and imply also a relation
between conflict and contest conversely
the cases I've discussed this morning
suggested a key characteristic of new
religious movements including in general
new movements within established
religions and including here the
movement to proceed an imposition from
the late 12th century may be to
eliminate cross-cutting ties by
prioritizing a particular identity in
Sens terminology a fanatic might be
defined as one who sees all conflicts
and issues from the perspective of a
single identity consequently the
language of religion may be deployed to
repudiate such ties and so facilitate
the violence that might otherwise be
inhibited that worked for the Arbor
champion Crusaders but neither heresy
nor crusade nor indeed Inquisition a
story that I haven't been able examine
here had dissolved or overridden the
traditional loyalties and solidarities
of akut and society among those
solidarities were traditional religious
ties variously interpreted but which
were not perceived by occitane Ian's as
overriding or exclusive of others like
there's a family and neighborhood this
conclusion runs contrary to a common
understanding of religion and especially
of religion violently expressed as the
embodiment of ancient and unchanging
communities and communal loyalties that
indeed is how it generally represents
itself and is represented both by its
spokespersons and by its adversaries it
was also the basis of the concept of
civilizations which in the 19th and 20th
centuries constituted the building
blocks of world history and the master
narratives of it that prevailed for most
of that period one of its byproducts
with particular implications for the
ways in which we thought about the
history of Europe and of the New York
for example was the image of traditional
non-european societies as stagnant and
unchanging set firm in the molds
fashioned by the prophets and scriptures
of their dominant religions it was an
image as much Marxist as famous and
still widely taken for granted only a
generational so ago now it's now
unimaginably remote except perhaps at
certain rather rarefied levels of the
stratosphere where turbulence in the
upper reaches of the Ivy League
occasionally precipitates ideological
overflow into think tanks and back in
the European Middle Ages to the contrary
religion and religious violence were
expressive and indeed constitutive of
new values and solidarities at all
levels of society of discarding the old
and entrenching the new
thank you very much professor okay we're
going to open it up for about 15 to 20
minutes of questions if you have
additional questions after that we'll
move it on to we'll save those questions
right after the now
I'm wondering
earlier
I'm not sure whether I call and let me
respond on reinterment I having first of
all thank you very much for your initial
point that the effect of dissolving
cross-cutting ties into um could be to
produce peace that certainly is true all
sorts of communities new communities
religious in which it was so so clearly
I'm the important question which I had
not asked tonight because I hadn't
thought of it is why does it work in the
given situation in what in one direction
rather than the other when they may be
that if I if I followed the second part
of your question right that the antidote
is something like this what I'm
suggesting is that what you what you had
in place on the eve of the Gregorian
reform in Western Europe and in this
respect it seems to me you could
replicate it very widely across
traditional societies and
was nests of local communities which had
got very neatly arranged structures for
distributing resources and power and
prestige within their particular local
hegemonies and the way that it worked
is absolutely clearly shown in the
Archdiocese of Milan where the after the
arrangement of 983 the archbishop in
fief the leading families of the
archdiocese with the lands of the
archbishop bring those provided the
revenues not only if their family but of
course for the church the positions in
the church were given to the younger
members of the families and they also
the families also elected the archbishop
effectively chose the officer it was it
was a sealed closed hermetic system and
as long as it worked like that then so
fast we can see from outside that was
fine what happened in Milan what
happened in lots of places in Western
Europe in this beard is that it stopped
working and there are a number of
reasons for that not all which I would
believe myself capable of identifying
but certainly to I think our great
importance and our are interacting one
is that the economy stopped being able
to support the level of
the level of consumption his system of
why because population was growing
slowly but it was growing and the
pressure on on the economy of coming to
break and the other was that it was
getting harder for society to remain
local society to remain hermetically
sealed they did start to have increasing
or starting to have increasing impacts
and one another so what happens in this
fear is that that system of social
organization is breaking down and it
can't really easily be replaced
gradually if you want to replace a
system of some semi pastoral small-scale
agriculture and that's a pretty crude
description but by and large that's what
predominant in Western Europe up to
around eleven century beginning if
you're going to replace that with
large-scale of cereal cultivation that
isn't something you can readily do in
worse conditions by half-measures
you have to reorganize on a very large
scale and I went I mean I would be
repeating my book if I went on but I
think that that's one of the things
which which makes the violence
inescapable that as it were gradualism
is not Nazi and not sure how far that
responds to what you are
well I think that's one of the big
questions which we only got part of the
way to to answering but if you reach
three where any account of European
history
from the late 11th century what you will
find is that it will give you a very
something there elephant account of
tremendous level of religious idealism
which was a teat and and central to that
is particularly the idea of rigidity and
especially a female fertility and cross
country in the eleventh 11th century
specially the earlier
it's metal virginity that gets the
headlines for the 12th century trips in
other words monogamy is being elevated
you'll get it you you were really
breaking about the part of chivalry the
club of chivalry is a way of getting
young men basically to go without until
they're quite old men in the great
majority of cases and persuade
themselves and it's but it's a good
thing to do similarly of course that's
what monasticism is about so I'm not
wanting to sound cynical but what I'm
saying is that if you look at the
religious movements including including
it is they are organized around these
ideas they're organized around the
sanctification of the new kind of
society which is no longer a rough
warrior band society in which the more
sons a man has by whatever whatever
source in which he alliances so what I
mean the general answer your question is
that it was done by producing more
people
the Renaissance and all that the
particular answer in my view has yet to
be there we know bits
question about to what extent does
violence that involves internal paratus
differ from violence
in the bottom so it was worse for my my
guess would be that once you cross the
line in which you say these people are
not about you then you do what you do
but I do emphasize guess if there's a
problem of course it's a problem sauce
they use a conventional language to
describe what happens in certain
contingencies and for what sense any
particular
as far as I can see yes
well I think we're going to break them
for about 15 minutes